kara is with us in Lexington Kentucky hi
Kara how are you I'm well and yourself
better than I deserve what's up great
quick question my husband and I we have
about seventy five thousand dollars in
student loan debt combined we have an
income roughly of seventy-five to eighty
thousand a year and we have paid off a
bunch of our little small that medical
bills and then my car
the only other debt that we have is his
currently all about eleven thousand on
it we just want to get all this knocked
out as soon as possible and it's kind of
overwhelming with such large numbers
this all that's for easy but the bigger
ones are kind of overwhelming to us well
yeah the debt snowball slows down to a
screeching halt once you get past the
little ones right and so we're still
going to list them smallest to largest
and we're still going to chunk away on
it and then I just start backing off I
kind of pan out and look at the scene a
little bit wider and that helps you have
a little bit more hope so you make
seventy five thousand you have eighty
six thousand dollars in debt if you're
going to do it in two years would be
forty three a year that's probably not
quite going to happen right probably
gonna take you closer to three years
yeah we were wanting to do three years
or less and also on top of that I am I
just applied and hopefully I will be
able to do it to teach children in China
English so that would be an extra income
from for me probably maybe up to six
hundred a month done remotely I take it
yes okay alright sure okay great
anything we can do but you know
basically what we're saying is about
three grand a month towards this debt
chunks it off so the card debt is how
much so three grand goes into eleven how
many times four months are done right
but we also have we have about fifteen
thousand dollars saved up right now oh
yeah Panther car today baby step one's a
thousand dollars anything above a
thousand dollar starts going towards his
debts
okay I'm sorry are you doing a written
budget yet we just started like an April
trying to be like a way you're doing the
budget of how much we spend and how much
we bring in and so we're kind of getting
a better idea where our money is going
but it still this is overwhelming we
don't know if we're doing it right or
not you're not doing it right I can tell
by the way you said that yeah I kind of
want to sorta get a feeling of where I'm
on no that's not how budget works that
it's not kind of sort of feeling it's
you write it down you know exactly what
you're going to spend on every category
and then you stick to it and you and
your husband pinkie-swear in spit shake
this is the freakin plan right so Joe
every dollar jump on every dollar and
download the every dollar app tonight
you and your husband go build a real
budget and a budget if you tell your
money what to do every dollar has a name
every dollar has an assignment before
the month begins every month and then
you stick to that and you stay out of a
restaurant you don't need to be inside a
restaurant unless you're working there
right you're broke okay and you don't
need to be talking about a vacation
you're broke yeah we've our discuss that
we don't need to take any vacations or
anything let's go eat or anything like
that
and we already cancelled we had one plan
but we cancelled it good good so what
happened is is that you've taken all the
big pieces and you put them in place and
the only step left for you is the fine
tuning and really just take take two
more steps down into the details okay
you're still hovering just above the
details on your budget as an example and
then you can get it and go okay three
thousand dollars a month
boom cars done in four months boom
$3,000 a month when's the student loan
gonna be done boom and we're gonna be
done with the whole thing eighty six
thousand bucks which is 11 plus seventy
five that your student loan plus your
car that you know three thousand a month
for 30 bar for you know for 30 months
doesn't right that's two and a half
years that sounds good there's something
I need to do with my student loan so as
I just like to know that the extras is
no ansible above my regular payment no
just our file yeah you just put
principal only on the pain
are you handed online and I thought well
no it automatically is it that's it from
my account every ok but see if you have
an online ability to pay most the time
they have principal only their selection
on that on the online page and you can
just say this goes to principal this
goes to principal you do not want to
prepay payments you want to pay
principal only payments is what you want
to do when you get to your student loan
but right now the first four months were
on your car and then we attack from
there so hey you're doing great you got
this view you got this down you got it
you got the ideas and you got the play
the big pieces in place so now let's
dive down in the details on this budget
tonight get this thing laid out and
because what's happened you kept saying
I'm overwhelmed the reason I know you're
not on your budget is if you had it all
laid out in detail it's not overwhelming
how do you eat an elephant a bite at a
time and you have a diagram of where to
take the first bite and that diagram is
called a budget every dollar has an
assignment that's my diagram on eating
this elephant it's an 86 thousand dollar
elephant that's gonna take 30 months you
can do it this is doable and and you get
this extra income you get other stuff
going on it may even happen faster than
that for you probably will actually but
we know we can doing 30 so it's not
overwhelming great job
proud of you